[Music]
on this wednesday night a critical point
at the climate summit
there's a draft deal at cop 26 but
what's missing from it we need much more
concrete action and a surprise new
pledge from two of the world's worst
polluters the excruciating effect of
postponing surgery i'm not having this
hysterectomy just because how long it
could take to clear the backlog of
surgeries delayed by covid
murderous motive what may have inspired
the man accused of running down a muslim
family in london ontario a global news
exclusive
and a century-old tale of bravery from
all accounts he was
a very good guy the long lost letter
that revealed a canadian airman's
poignant story
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
time is running out for the nearly 200
countries at the u.n climate summit to
agree on what they'll do to keep a lid
on rising temperatures a draft agreement
released today sets the stage for
last-minute negotiations now underway it
urges countries to revisit and
strengthen their targets it says
vulnerable nations must get more help to
cope with the deadly impacts of global
warming and calls on countries to
accelerate the phasing out of coal and
subsidies for fossil fuels but has no
firm dates or targets scientists have
warned that keeping temperature rises to
1.5 degrees celsius beyond which the
worst impacts of climate change will be
felt requires global emissions to be cut
by 45 percent by 2030 and down to zero
by 2050 we are not on target to meet
that now it is clear there's a sense of
urgency and today china and the us the
two largest emitters in the world
promise to work together on cutting
emissions crystal gomansing has our top
story tonight
with a clock ticking down in glasgow a
preview today at how far negotiators
have come in hammering out a new climate
deal the draft document urges countries
to ramp up efforts to phase out coal and
fossil fuel subsidies but critics are
warning it's not enough
we need much more concrete action to be
sure that we actually really need this
1.5 target activists say the six-page
draft lacks clear deadlines and is short
on specifics as to how key areas will be
addressed there's also no language
requiring countries to be transparent
about their progress what we need to do
is to streamline the text because the
best decision is a short decision that
is clear for everybody and there is no
room for alternate facts or alternate
interpretation
boris johnson reappeared at the summit
wednesday as the draft copy of the
glasgow agreement landed with a thud
he's urging countries to pull out all
the stops to limit global warming will
you help us
grasp that opportunity or will you stand
in the way developing nations bearing
the brunt of the crisis say they need
more support they've been clear they
need wealthier nations to step up
financially the draft calls on countries
to urgently scale up climate financing
but no deadlines are attached i think
it's important to recognize
that ambition also requires technology
that there is
inadequate
adaptation and financial efforts to tap
the impacts of the climate crisis with
just two days to go a positive signal
the world's two largest emitters the u.s
and china announced a surprise deal to
work together to tackle climate change
together we set out our support
for a successful cop 26. now it's up to
negotiators to get firm commitments on
paper i still think we can achieve it
but i'm not going to pretend to you that
it is by any means a a done deal johnson
has already hinted talks could extend
past friday
crystal gomanson global news london
in ontario the seven day average of
daily new coven 19 cases has risen above
500 again and that's led the province to
delay lifting capacity limits for higher
risk settings like nightclubs and
wedding halls the province's top doctor
says ontario though is still on the
right track
ontarians are still adhering to all the
best practices unlike other places where
they've taken on and and then taken off
um and then had to put back in
public health measures we've remained
constant
ontario's seven day average for new
cases is up 44 percent since the
beginning of november but hospital and
icu numbers have remained stable
in alberta and saskatchewan covet 19
case counts are now coming down after a
punishing fourth wave intensive care
units were so overwhelmed some patients
were transferred out of province and
thousands of surgeries were delayed as
heather urex west explains it could take
months to clear the backlog for leah
crawford a difficult fourth wave of
covid19 led to four additional months of
pain it's unimaginable because you know
i'm i'm in enough pain
as it is you know i'm i'm not having
this hysterectomy just because
you know i'm having it for a reason the
calgary woman one of thousands to have a
surgery postponed as alberta struggled
to cope with a surge in covet patients
that nearly brought the health system to
its knees with that surge now subsiding
doctors are once again in the or though
the system is nowhere near back to full
capacity i'm still operating only a
fraction of the time i normally operate
so
i i anticipate it will take months
before we're able to work through the
backlog for sure it's
been very difficult to find operative
time to deal with these cancers that
have a tendency to grow very quickly dr
oliver bathe treats gi liver and
pancreatic cancer patients patients with
often aggressive tumors that may have
seen their disease spread during the
delay that's too soon to tell
you know i think it'll be a long time
before we understand fully what the
impact of this is on people's cancer
prognosis alberta health services is now
prioritizing pediatric and cancer
patients but the backlog for other
surgeries may take longer to clear last
week the saskatchewan health authority's
ceo said it could be 18 months before
that province is able to perform
orthopedic surgeries again i think it's
going to be tremendously hard you know
we were already working in a system that
was
restrained in terms of the number of
surgeries and meeting surgical targets
in terms of wait times for surgeries
with thousands of additional patients
now in the queue the surgery backlog
represents another wave of extraordinary
health system strain heather urex west
global news calgary
covid 19 cases are rising in the
northwest territories there are more
than 50 active cases in the region now
but a third of them are in tuktoyaktuk
health officials believe there's
community transmission there in the
community of about 900. a 10-day
lockdown has now been ordered in hopes
of slowing the spread of the virus
and please
i'm begging you get vaccinated
and yukon's premier says there is now
widespread and untraceable community
transmission of covid19 in whitehorse
the territory declared a state of
emergency on monday new restrictions
will be enforced beginning saturday
including a mandatory proof of
vaccination requirement for people age
12 and over the territory has the
highest rate of active cases in the
country
the leader of the green party of canada
anime paul has formally resigned and she
has quit the party in a tweet today paul
said it was an honor to work for the
people of canada and i look forward to
serving in new ways paul was at the helm
for just one year it was tumultuous she
dealt with infighting within the party
over her leadership and lost her own
riding in the federal election
after a five-year pause there's going to
be a sequel to the so-called three
amigos summit prime minister justin
trudeau and mexican president lopez
obrador will be the guests of u.s
president joe biden in washington
jackson prescott joins me from there now
jackson they've met before virtually i
guess but this will be the first time in
person what's on the agenda
well that's right donna officially the
leaders are set to talk about issues
like climate change migration and ending
the pandemic but it's what they are not
advertising that will likely dominate
the meeting namely the impacts of
biden's buy american policies on
canadian and mexican companies both
countries are looking for exemptions
there there's also concern about a u.s
tax credit program on electric vehicles
that cuts out foreign-made cars again
that's a serious concern for the
canadian auto sector then there's the
fate of enbridge line five that pipeline
that faces court challenges here in the
united states and of course you can
expect a collective push from canada and
mexico for biden to develop some sort of
north american strategy for standing up
to china
the question will be whether biden will
take up their cause and that's one of
the challenges in north america it seems
as though it's three amigos all for one
and one for all when the u.s wants
canada and mexico to tow the line but
when canada and mexico want something it
sometimes seems like well it's america
first even under biden
interesting well jackson and canada and
the us do have a solid relationship but
domestic pressures do take precedence
all the time is that much different
under president biden than it was under
trump
so far no and i think that could lead to
some real pressure behind the scenes to
develop a more reciprocal relationship
that's something that completely
vanished in the trump years and really
has not been rebuilt in the first year
of the biden presidency both canada and
mexico are likely to look for some sort
of signal that biden supports their
interests and is willing to strengthen
those ties but of course the politics
are very complicated here as you
mentioned donna and this summit is
happening at a time when biden's
domestic popularity has plummeted and
democrats in congress have struggled to
get things done in other words there may
be only so much that biden can bend on
all right jackson proskow in washington
thanks
in the u.s there is a clear indication
how fast prices are rising inflation has
hit the highest rate in three decades
the consumer price index the amount
people pay for goods and services
recorded a 6.2 percent increase year
over year in october the fastest annual
pay since 1990 the price of nearly
everything is up but the biggest rises
are energy costs shelter food and
vehicles the combination of a tight
labor market supply chain problems and
increasing consumer demand are pushing
up prices higher inflation has persisted
much longer than most economists
predicted they do think it will begin to
slow once supply bottlenecks clear
the u.s house committee investigating
the january sixth attack on the capital
have been given access to former
president donald trump's white house
records a judge rejected trump's request
to block the release of the documents
writing that presidents are not kings
and the plaintiff is not president the
hundreds of pages could shed light on
the violent attack by trump's supporters
there are call logs drafts of speeches
and notes from trump's then chief of
staff barring a court order they could
be turned over to the committee as soon
as friday trump's lawyers plan to appeal
so the case will likely head to the u.s
supreme court
there is some new insight tonight into
what may have influenced the man accused
of killing a muslim family in london
ontario in june global news has learned
investigators found written information
that appears to show he was inspired by
the gunman who killed 51 people at two
new zealand mosques in 2019. as mike
cherle reports it could explain why
canadian officials modified the charges
against him soon after the attack
there was never a doubt as to what
happened in the early evening of june 6
in london ontario muslim canadian family
out for a stroll was killed allegedly
run over by a truck driven by nathaniel
veltman as police built their case the y
was hinted at but never fully explained
even though the muslim community had
made up its mind they all know what it
was
there was no
doubt right from the get-go that this
was an act of terror global news has now
learned from multiple sources that
police found a large volume of
ideological writings in the suspect's
truck home and computer which allegedly
showed he was heavily influenced by
brenton tarant who live streamed a
portion of his attack on two mosques in
christchurch new zealand in 2019. police
also found documents allegedly written
by veltman that referenced durant which
may explain why veltman later became the
first person charged under canada's
anti-terrorism laws for an alleged
islamophobic act i can't keep showing up
at funerals and learning afterwards
about who was how they were motivated
you know how much white supremacist
literature did they consume
i i don't want to do that anymore and i
know that community muslims don't want
to do that anymore and that's why it has
to stop it has to change but the
opposite appears to be true a report
from canada's integrated terrorism
assessment center acquired by global
news through the freedom of information
act points to manifestos becoming far
more common with extremists and are
meant to resonate with like-minded
individuals
taran's manifesto in particular has
inspired others he also laced his uh
his manifesto with
jokes and irony things that would appeal
to the internet generation
um things that are kind of inside jokes
in certain chat rooms and so even while
he displayed this incredible level of
barbarity he's still doing it with a
wink and a nod to internet culture and i
think that really resonated with the far
right our call is simple
no more violence earlier this week the
national council of canadian muslims
released our london family act which
would target islamophobia through
education and accountability they want
the ontario government to act
urgently
mike relay global news toronto
canadian catholic bishops say they plan
to send a small delegation to rome next
month when indigenous leaders meet with
pope francis in a statement the bishops
say 25 to 30 first nations inuit and
metis elders knowledge keepers
residential school survivors and youth
will meet with pope francis at the
vatican from december 17th to 20th the
pope will participate in private
meetings with them
well even prime ministers face
distractions when working from home
oh it is i'm sorry darling it is taking
so long okay
coming up how a three-year-old asserted
herself during a live briefing
working from home can be tricky for
parents of young kids even when your
prime minister new zealand's prime
minister jacinda ardern was giving a
live update about covid19 when this
happened
you meant to be in bed darling
it's bedtime darling pop back to bed
i'll come and see you in a second
i'll come and see you in a minute okay
sorry everybody well that was a bedtime
fail wasn't it
um
sorry everyone i thought here's a moment
i'll do a facebook live we're nice and
safe
our durian tried to continue but
three-year-olds can be persistent
oh it is i'm sorry darling it is taking
so long okay i'm sorry everyone i'm
gonna just go and put leave back to bed
um
because this is well past 2b time
it's not the first time she's had to
keep her cool last month an earthquake
hit while she was in the middle of a
press conference she just gripped the
podium and called it a slight
distraction
the push to recognize canada's punjabi
soldiers ahead their pivotal role in the
first world war
[Music]
there are lots of forgotten or
overlooked stories in canada's military
history one is about the role of punjabi
troops especially during the first world
war few are aware of the critical role
they played in a pivotal battle now a
historian is advocating for long overdue
recognition neto garcia explains
after four days without respite it was
these indian soldiers who were called in
by the canadians as reinforcements in
the second battle of eep on april 26
1915 helping to stop the advance of
german forces without the participation
of the punjabi soldiers
eeps would have been lost the canadian
forces wouldn't have actually been able
to hold the line
at eep in a war about 1.3 million indian
soldiers served in more than canadians
australians and new zealanders combined
we will literally have punjabi the kin
of the punjabi that are on the kamagata
maru fighting to defend the canadian
line in flanders through this exhibit at
the museum of surrey bc historian
stephen purawal is sharing these often
forgotten stories of selfless service a
pillar of the faith these sick vancouver
police officers say motivates them i
think our faith plays a major role in
that and
it's a part of our fabric is to serve
the community the men that fought in
that war uh
ensured that i could stand here today
with a turban and a beard in a in a
vancouver police department uniform
both officers are also part of this
heritage film written and directed by
purowal but like his efforts to have the
untold stories of six soldiers
incorporated into social studies
curriculums across canada he's run into
barriers we're still looking for more
funding what are the priorities it is a
common experience too of being colonials
he's also turned this exhibit into a
book which he's giving to every canadian
mp i did not understand before coming
here that india had the second largest
standing army at the time of world war
one to britain especially on the 100
year anniversary of the poppy coinciding
with the 50th anniversary of canada's
first multiculturalism policy purowall
says it's time to correct the narrative
which i feel has a eurocentric lens
to the detriment of many many minority
communities nito garcia global news
surrey bc
up next a long lost letter reveals what
happened to a young canadian pilot after
his plane went down
we observe remembrance day every
november 11th because it marks the end
of the first world war this next story
is about a pilot who was injured just
before it ended as he lay in a british
hospital his sister came to visit from
canada and she sent a letter home that
letter is now helping his family bring
his story to life
redmond shannon reports
dear marjorie i hardly know how to write
to you for as you will know it is not
easy for me to go through everything
again a century-old letter telling a
heartbreaking tale of first world war
pilot lieutenant james gordon moore as
my grandmother says gordon and his
machine
maureen kitchen's grandmother was
moore's cousin in 1916 the 21 year old
enlisted for the war flying bombing
missions into germany with britain's
royal flying corps and later becoming a
test pilot from all accounts he was
a very good guy his sisters all
obviously
adored him
just three weeks before the war ended
moore's plane crashed in france he was
thrown clear but was horribly burned
when trying to save the australian
co-pilot his older sister thursa sailed
from canada to england to be with him at
his bedside
after 10 long months of suffering
lieutenant moore died in a london
hospital a grieving thursday wrote to
her sister marjorie about gordon's final
days
he often said to me that he couldn't
bear to have people see him he was so
sensitive
and really i do feel gordon was happy to
go
he was so peaceful i stayed with him and
i held him for a long time but i knew
i knew he was going he was so thin
and had failed so terribly
they told me to leave him as they didn't
want me to see him die so i kissed him
and he said yes goodbye
maureen found the letter in her parents
house a decade ago unearthing a family
pain sealed for decades inside an
envelope
i know how hard it will be to us as
gordon was everything to us but we must
not be selfish and wish him back for he
has surely had his suffering
gordon was simply worshipped by the
flyers over here and they never stopped
talking about his bravery the letter
details moore's full military funeral at
this london cemetery you could tell in
that letter that really helped them
deal with the fact that he was gone it
was
he didn't he did not die in vain maureen
believes his four sisters were never the
same again their only solace that gordon
was finally at peace
redmond shannon global news london
and that's global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen as we
prepare for remembrance day we leave you
tonight with photos from the national
military cemetery in ottawa the final
resting place for thousands of canadians
who have given their lives in service to
this country
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
you